Japan is opening its borders.
From October 11, Japan will relax border control measures...
...to be on par with the U.S....
...as well as resume visa-free travel and individual travel.
From the 11th of October,...
...Japan will restore individual tourism and visa waiver travel...
...to people from certain countries...
...as long as they're vaccinated.
It will also scrap a daily cap on arrivals currently set at 50,000.
It's a key step in fostering a recovery in Japan's tourism sector,...
...which is eager to take advantage of the yen's slide to a 24-year low.
Japan has maintained some of the strictest border measures among major economies...
...since the pandemic's onset,...
...having effectively blocked entry to visitors for two years...
...until it began a gradual reopening in June.